after this whole article I don't know
who the bad guy is I think it's us dude
I think we're the baddies are we the
baddies I think who are the baddies
we're the baddies we're the baddies I
don't agree with you guys don't have
mentality I can't tell what side we're
on
[Music]
so there's a there's a woman her name's
Karen McGee
Karen she is a deaf 71 year old Florida
resident she is considering a lawsuit
against the City of Austin Texas after
what was supposed to be a simple
three-hour layover at Austin Bergstrom
International Airport but it turned into
an arrest in an ordeal oh three hours
she had her arm broken by a Jailer and
she was left untreated for three days
what the [__] what happened September
13th 2022 she was waiting for a
connecting flight from Austin to Seattle
very simple
she's flying along for the first time in
her life and very nervous because her
hearing aids weren't working well she is
off after all death
so she sat within site of the ticket
desk to make sure she knew when her plan
would begin to board very cute and
innocent
after noticing it hadn't boarded on time
she spoke with a ticket agent and was
distressed to learn that she had missed
an announcement that her gate had
changed because she is deaf that's why
you gotta have the app the app the
update live no you're gonna have
somebody next to take an agent who's
like doing a lot the whole time well
even the most respectful way of doing it
by the way even if she was next to the
ticket agent in the booth like it would
say it on the screen yeah it would she
really wasn't paying attention to that
yeah right but you do got to get that
after Alpha the app updates live like
when you're watching the Dropbox worried
face watch Joe Biden talk he's got some
lady like on the side yep yeah yeah I
mean I've had a gaming headset on at the
gate and I could tell when they change
Gates and that's pretty much like very
simple yeah but you're so zany but is it
you just see everybody there's a shot
like normal protocol to go to your gate
first and look at the departure thing on
the [__] wall but this lady was like
really on it right she was like trying
to make sure she knew so she was very
distressed no we don't think so we think
she's full of [__] we'll give her the
benefit of the downtown there's more
she texted her cousin great she learned
that there was another plane parked at
the same gate going the same destination
she approaches the ticket agent and she
asked if she could switch her ticket to
that flight
she had trouble hearing the agent's
response but understood the answer was
no yeah like whatever it was because
that's not how it works you can't buy a
ticket at that [__] counter you gotta
ask though she then made the same
request to a different agent and
unbeknownst to her the second agent
called the police oh [__] she's probably
already getting irate huh yeah maybe
she's missing out the part where she
called him a [__] [__] and she'll
beat her ass well you don't know right
and also 71 year old deaf woman yeah you
don't know how she's presenting and then
the ticket agent has no idea with her
situation and the closest person that I
know that was deaf is pretty much my
pops he had hearing aids when he didn't
have those [__] in he's
screaming ah so you don't even know like
she could just be straight yelling yeah
what time he's the next fly
what happened
what'd it say
it's basically her her lawyer is
basically like hey look if you want to
hurt my ears
why you tell me we come so close for
dude I didn't want to lean in honestly
your ears are big enough because that's
why ears are [__] up enough too people
always say that too in the comments it
hurts my feelings that's true because I
could hear this
[Laughter]
why are they spending so much money on
having NASA [__] in space just said
Nick's ears out there it's all steamed
right into the comments my favorite
things when like people on Tick Tock
make fun of his ears and then other
people comment and they go look up look
up what cauliflower ear is and you're
not going to want to make fun of them
and then they always come back and go oh
my bad okay destroy them dude Crush
their souls the the loud the Big Ear
jokes they get immediately scared so why
is NASA was gonna show when they can
send her ears up there that's a i i this
is something I write a lot a lot in the
comments and I just never saw a good
answer it's a good question nobody
rebuttal that Ryan her lawyer basically
says unless you get on her level her
hearing aids can't pick you up and so
like she has a real problem receiving
the communications that's very true yeah
um you would know so there you go that
helps but then because half the time I'm
like Dad does your hearings even work
because I'm talking to them and he can't
even hear me still but you have to speak
at a certain frequency and you got to
speak at your level they barely and then
when they're working you can hear them
working you can almost hear your own uh
echo in his ear like a megaphone like a
walkie-talk like you'll hear your own
voice like in an electronic way going in
there you're like oh okay so now it's
picking me up oh I see yeah that's crazy
I didn't know that it's cool so all she
knows is she's like okay I asked for
this to happen
and now I'm in a wheelchair and I'm
pushed to the front of the airport and I
think they'll rebook in my flight that's
pretty good news and then as soon as she
gets outside they start handcuffing her
Cops start handcuffing her they take her
to Travis County Jail on suspicion of
trespassing oh [__] and she says all I
did was stand up and they're all around
me and I don't remember them saying
anything to me or even to each other and
then she said they shove me against a
wall they started stripping me down on
my clothes and she screams not my ring
when the offers are starting to remove
her ring right what what she said an
officer then told her something she
didn't understand she asked what an in
response a different officer Twisted her
handcuffs with enough Force to break her
arm which that's what happened oh these
guys I mean she's 71 right she's an old
lady is she and she's in a wheelchair
did they think she was homeless or
something I don't know trespassing they
must have thought this is like man yo
Handle With Care she's 71. so and then
what are you gonna strip her down like
that what do you think she's got on her
dude all because no one could
communicate well she's at the station
right because when they process her they
have to well they do they have to strip
I don't think they have to strip her but
they gotta search her I just feel like a
71 year old you just like treat a little
different though yeah I'm no cop but but
that would be reverse ageist oh [__]
that's right I don't want to be there I
need to learn this yeah that's kind of
[__] up
strip them all so she says she lost time
I said strip mall she lost time after
this incident she wakes up in her jail
cell she has her clothes back on but
they're inside out her arm is aching she
was given a leave
which is like for headaches and [__] and
like pain I've never broken arms are you
laughing at her clothing yeah it's funny
when somebody gets her arm broken
she wakes it with her clothes on but
it's
pretty interesting
you're right oh my God yeah that's weird
close inside out what could have
happened Gwyneth Paltrow's [__] was
quivering
I read that too right off of the [__]
copy really
okay so the a police officer calls
emergency tech technical emergency
technician who helped her contact her
husband and get her into a hotel after
um she left the jail cell after three
days of detention damn in Austin and um
uh yes in uh it doesn't say it says she
had a surgeon on her arm after making it
home to Florida so she gets surgery in
Florida [__] at the Austin jail they
gave her some barbecue
and baked beans I sure hope some Terry
blacks some collard greens those Inside
Out barbecues is it blacks or teres
right
so she's for real untreated broken arm
in the jail cell it's been awesome for
three days cops just [__] her up and
he gave her some relief where's where's
the camera footage man I know it's crazy
dude I want to hear what the cops have
to say like we I thought she was a
[__] threat
like I want to hear all that yeah she
was she was irate
and we thought she was a part of Isis
it's like we didn't know what she had on
her we got two weeks in her pocket could
have been a grenade we don't know turned
out there were some Heavies dude if I
was a cop easily if a person was being
[__] annoying I'd be like oh you're
being a threat in a twister arm yeah
right you know I do that that's why I'm
not a cop because I'd be so corrupt
you'd be power hungry corrupt I'd be
[__] elbowing the [__] out of their
[__] back on accident shut up grab on
you [__] too loud seems like a lot of
Joes became cops out there nowadays huh
these Joes give cops a bad name or maybe
we're the stupid ones because they're
dealing with criminals all day every day
and maybe most criminals are 71 year old
ladies yeah we're deaf
we're just that's a super just buy it I
mean like
yeah but why don't we let the
professionals handle professional [__]
like I mean am I out there battling
criminals every day nah no not at all
yeah so who's doing the real crookin 71
year old ladies clearly fast ones on
everybody yeah and if you're on Wheels
you can move faster let's be real
especially if it's electric you're more
Nimble even with a broken arm electric
yeah oh yeah those would be boobs well
you only need one arm for that so she's
probably gonna get a nice settlement if
you get a product scooter we got 12
points of movement
no because Texas doesn't negotiate with
terrorists wow just Texas yeah Texas
goes we don't negotiate hostage
situations but we serve barbecue in jail
only behind closed doors we do negotiate
with naked terrorists which is why we
had to remove her clothing oh that's
right and then we put it back on inside
out yeah that's [__] up dude they knew
what they were doing it's a funny little
prank it is a good prank though if you
think about it it's like dude we put on
one inside
they're one of their jeans tags out tags
up after this whole article I don't know
who the bad guy is I think it's us dude
I think we're the baddies are we the
baddies I think we're the baddies we're
the baddies we're the baddies I don't
agree with you guys don't have mentality
I can't tell what side we're on
the the uh
uh cops and the grandma Yeah benefit of
the doubt but we're like why what if
they treat it why would they treat her
like I think the basic thing is oh I
can't believe these cops she's just the
innocent old lady [__] these racist cops
let's go wait was the lady black I don't
know I hope she was because if it's my
narrative okay because there was nothing
to do with racing but if she was a 71
year old white lady oh it doesn't fit my
narrative her name's McGee how bad could
she be
hey but but also though like what if
sure her clothes were on backwards the
whole time oh so when they flip it
inside out
whether she's deaf or not she might be
also like what if she's a little crazy
and what if she's like well she's a
little nut she's a fawn guard yeah and
she had her clothes on backwards all the
deaf people watching this right now
they're gonna be like just because we
can't hear it doesn't mean that we
stupid well at least they can watch it
exactly that's true they could read it
yeah but they at least they can't write
angry in our comments thank God
oh wait but they probably could huh yeah
should we put this one on patreon I
don't think that's how deafness works we
should submit this one for a streaming I
think it's gonna be really good but I
think we're just thinking out loud yo we
don't have any room for more streamings
dude just trying to help Crack the Case
yeah really we're just reporting the
news you got a real winner on our hands
we're just trying theories you know what
I mean I don't know about you guys but
the word death was so positive when I
was growing up you want to be called
that dude this is your Santa bit for
Death Row Records right so depth fresh
to death Germaine Dupree I'm still
wondering if Karen McGee is black no no
no no now we got it this is her and I
like the cops like oh they both need
hands on her she's like damn she's a
[__] threat I don't have a video I
don't know man I didn't release it she
looks blind she looks like she that
looks like a white supremacist officer
taking down a good old perch she looks
like a fake lady while she's wearing
glasses if she's deaf she does look like
a dummy yeah she looks like and not like
a dumb person but more like uh like a
scarecrow mannequin like a mannequin
like a fake person yeah yeah like she'd
be standing at Macy's why is she wearing
those sunglasses I thought she was deaf
not blind that's what I thought yeah do
you think she'd be having me earmuffs on
I think you know what she's checking her
clothes are on backwards I don't like
this I don't like this handicap
appropriation [__] bro she's doing
it
I am deaf here's our streaming
opportunity right here no no it should
end this video
I'm deaf I think cops I'm trying to get
the cops back if they if she started off
saying I'm deaf then the cops can treat
her accordingly I'm like oh she can't
hear that's why she's screaming at us
then I think the cops at fault but if
she never said that and she's just
screaming and being hysterical they
might think she's on fentanyl or some
[__] we better take this [__] down
exactly true yeah that's what I've been
saying this whole time I don't know I
think I think she's gonna get a nice
settlement I think so that's my
prediction like and this barbecue for
her whole life what was the place called
Blackberry black Terry blacks one of the
jury's all deaf I don't think they could
do that that's bias oh that's right it's
called blacks and and their Rivals are
Smitty's that's what it was not Terry's
and blacks to me I just don't get the
big deal about like so her arm got
popped out like she could just melt
Gibson and Lethal Weapon right
she needs to watch more movies yeah it's
so stupid the story's a little hokey
yeah why she wait three days for
laughs
I can't wait for antifa to come defend
her
[Music]
foreign